combien y a-t-il de quart d'heure dans
trois quarts d'heure seule la moitié des
élèves de 6e sont capables de répondre à
cette question c'est ce que révèle une
note d'alerte publiée le 20 septembre
par le Conseil scientifique de
l'éducation nationale sa conclusion une
inquiétante mécompréhension des nombres
et surtout des fractions chez les élèves
qui sortent de l'école primaire pour
beaucoup les nombres décimaux et les
fractions n'ont aucun sens or la
compréhension de ces outils
mathématiques est indispensable à la
mesure de n'importe quelle dimension
physique pour dresser ce constat les
experts ont notamment élaboré un test
informatique simple sur une ligne
graduée de 0 à 5 les futurs collégiens
doivent placer la fraction 1/2 résultat
seul 22% d'entre eux réussissent les
erreurs révèlent aussi une vaste
confusion entre différents types de
nombres et une méconnaissance du sens
des symboles les élèves confondent donc
un demi avec 1,2 ou encore 2 sur 1 avec
2,1 même constat pour les nombres
décimaux beaucoup sont persuadés
qu'additionnés 0,8 et 1 donne 0,9 le
plus inquiétant est que ce déficit de
compréhension conc tous les milieux
sociaux 85% en éducation prioritaire
mais presque 75% hors éducation
prioritaire et dans les écoles privées
par ailleurs quel que soit le milieu les
filles font beaucoup plus d'erreurs que
les garçons ces chiffres ne font que
confirmer les résultats des enquêtes
internationales pizza et TIMS qui
soulignent le retard considérable des
élèves français en mathématiques dans
cette discipline la France occupe la
dernière place en Europe or sur les
trois dernières années aucune évolution
positive n'a été enregistrée selon le
Conseil Scientifique la solution
introduire les concepts mathématiques
plutôt de façon progressive et intuitive
Singapour leader des classements
internationaux est pris pour exemple les
fractions ils sont introduites dès le
CE1 soit 2 ans avant la France